ivan is the first man to fly a hot-air
balloon
underground this cave is twice the
height of the Statue of Liberty and a
very tight squeeze this does not look
safe to me a slight gust of wind could
crash him into the wall rip his balloon
and sent him and his propane gas tank
plummeting to the cave floor we caught
up with Ivan in Austria to ask why do
this
aspectek Mahima meet no.2 says there are
a hank Rosa I'm Tyra the masked let the
tears of embraced her here Tom mom came
and asleep in forest on the filete
Eaters and itís pretty well ECT Karapiro
hunter hunting makes me for sure uber
employer so tennessee ticket back home
how can i even use a hot air balloon to
descend inside this cave to pull off
this record i even reduce the diameter
of his balloon by 8 meters or 25 feet
but because it was smaller it had less
lifting power and so he couldn't have as
much white underneath he swapped out the
regular passenger area with a steel
frame and dual propane gas tax which he
sat on if he had collided into the side
walls of the cave they could have
exploded the gas plan explosion is
Nutella hello Kansas arkus-duntov
unmentioned even if he added the Centers
of a camera
Minoru non-self table in D&D as with
infrared to be enough info traffic onion
descending into the cave itself wasn't
straight forward it slopes off to one
side and so he had to put two vents in
the hot hair balloon both facing the
same way so when air was released out of
them he was able to steer and follow the
slope of the cave
so polish eva then entry key shaft Ave
is not relief instigate working under
set system T Hulya serie a Sunanda cake
eggman after 10 heart-stopping minutes
ivan manages to land on the cave floor
ivan yodels in the face of danger
but getting to the bottom was the easy
part and all of the way down the cave
was dangerous the way back up was even
more dangerous because now the balloon
was blocking his view and he actually
collided with the walls of the cave five
times a day STP room tahula mitten
spittin faizon Varun teja priyanka comon
me fuego stage does campus event a
balloonist and lost accountant da he
notices via malice or of tees incapable
a rosca Khamenei's tan hibiscus renown
kayuu headstone a fat